-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with the one,
the only Alan Cumming.
And, obviously,
a job like yours requires
a little bit of discretion
on a show like this.
Are you a
good keeper of secrets?
-Uh, what do you think?
No.
-You seem like someone who would
really enjoy telling a secret.
-I love it.
-Yeah.
-I can't keep secrets.
You know, like,
my worst one was --
You know in "The Good --"
Remember in "The Good Wife"?
-Yeah.
-I was in that.
And there was a bit
when Will got shot and died.
Will was,
you know, the leading guy,
and Alicia was his --
They were having an affair.
It was all this big thing.
And he gets shot,
and it was a big thing.
And it was
actually one of these things --
it was hard to believe they
actually could keep it a secret,
because when it went out on TV,
the whole country was like,
"What?!"
-Yep. It was a big deal.
It was the kind of character
you didn't think
would get killed off.
-Well, I was also surprised that
nobody found out,
because I told everybody.
And I was -- I just --
I just couldn't keep it secret.
I was just -- People would say,
"Oh, hey,
I really love 'The Good Wife.'"
"Will's going to die."
And there was
one time when I was --
I was doing a fashion thing
and I sat down
to get my
hair and makeup done,
and the hair guy --
And I told the hairdresser.
I just -- I mean, never tell
hairdressers secrets.
They're worse than me.
But I just told everybody.
It was like a sort of --
What's that thing where you --
Tourette's, you know?
-Yeah.
You got secrets Tourette's.
-But nobody found out.
-Wow! Unbelievable.
-Yeah.
-You told the right people.
You told the right people
your secrets.
-Yes, I'm choosey, I suppose.
Yeah.
-You have a film coming out
called "Marlowe" --
a fantastic cast -- Liam Neeson,
Diane Kruger, Jessica Lange.
You've worked with
Jessica Lange before.
-Several times, actually.
She's an absolute hoot.
And, you know, it's
Liam Neeson's 100th film.
-Wow!
-Isn't that incredible?
-That's a really
nice thing to hit.
-Yes. And it was lovely.
We made it in Barcelona,
pretending to be L.A.
in the '30s.
And, yeah -- And I love --
Jessica Lange and I -- we did
"Titus" and we did another one.
And she's hilarious.
I actually talk about her
in my new --
my concert show
that I've been doing.
I was just in Australia.
It's called "Alan Cumming
Is Not Acting His Age."
And I tell this story about
how, one time,
we were making -- doing "Titus."
And you know, like,
in the middle of filming,
you're hanging around,
you're chatting, and gossiping.
And we were talking --
Jessica and I were talking about
the way -- the effects of
gravity on your body.
-As you get older.
-Exactly.
And she was saying that her
boobs were getting a bit saggy.
I said, "Well, my balls have
gone south, let me tell you."
And so we were
having a laugh about that.
Then, weeks later,
we were doing this other scene
where we're naked, and I'm sort
of asleep on top of her.
And I'm lying on top of her.
There's one hand on her boob,
and I'm sort of asleep
on her chest.
And having a laugh
in between takes.
And she -- At one point,
I say to her,
"Gosh, Jess, you know, I don't
know what you're talking about.
You have fantastic boobs."
And she said, "Honey,
if your hand wasn't there,
that thing would be
halfway around my back."
[ Laughter ]
-Do you think,
at this point, people are like,
"I want to give Alan
a really good story
so I can make
his next one-man show"?
-Yes.
-I feel like people talk to you
the way they talk
in, like, 1950,
like, banter films.
-It is a bit like that.
But, also, like, it's bizarrely
because I do have
a problem keeping secrets --
or I do keep, like,
when it's a proper secret,
if someone doesn't want me
to tell something.
But things like that, I do --
I'm sort of mouthy.
But also, conversely,
people tell me things.
Like, I've got -- I think people
feel comfortable
to tell me
their innermost secrets.
-It seems like maybe a bad call.
-[ Humming ]
-Oh, no!
We got to get out of here
before I tell you something.
Hey, it's always such
a pleasure to see you.
Congratulations on the show.
-Thank you.
-Alan Cumming!
"The Traitors"
streaming now on Peacock.
We'll be right back with
Jonathan Groff.